we have a great guest yes a great friend
to the chess club we have ed gonzalez
our super fan
and our statistician all right welcome
to our show ed
well for the u.s championship at least
this is ed's
big event he always comes we see him
every single year
and uh ed just loves it he's always
bringing me some stats and
and little files maurice take a look got
some great stats this year
well ed welcome to the show first of all
tell us why is it that you love the u.s
championship so much
um it's just a tournament i started
following
when i was a kid when i get my chest
life magazine i was always curious
who was winning and then um one day i
got a
like one of those um chess-based
databases and it had all the cross
tables and all the games and i just said
i can do a lot with this information and
i just started compiling
all the stats together you know and i i
was driven by that and i
keep adding to it every single year
that's awesome i know that you've given
up
you're in charge of the march madness
pool at your job
and you gave up that to come for the u.s
championship yeah what are your
what are your friends back home saying
where's that i hope somebody else is
running the pool this year that's all
well the timings early didn't work out
as well now you provided you've been
providing some great stats
about this and past events as well
anything that's jumping out at you this
time about this event
i love streaks you know i i really like
the fact that somebody like varus played
in 16 in a row and i know
he's he's chasing the record for most
consecutive
tournaments played in and who's that
what's that joel benjamin played in 24.
wow in a row i think he skipped one and
or one or two and then he came back and
um
i like the fact that wesley's on this
unbeaten streak
since 2015 and what's that number
uh he's uh what round is this uh he's
he started off at uh 35 and uh
so he's uh at 40 now joel benjamin
uh i was unbeaten for 44 in a row so uh
he could be caught and uh go into like
fifth place on the
all-time uh unbeaten streak uh because
sammy roshewski had 82 in a row and
that's going to be tough to catch i was
playing in those 17 rounders you know
back in the 40s and
we have these 11 rounders here it's it's
going to be tough to go it is going to
be tough now let
i want to try to stump you our panel
will be trying to stump you on any
kind of stat lines so tell us who had
you talked about unbeaten streak who had
the worst losing streak
worst losing streak uh i would say
shirazi probably
camera remember when he lost was the one
berkeley 1984 1984 he had a half a point
out of 17
or uh 15
i think it was 16 16 play around robin
yeah he had a half a point
that was actually an 18 round play
around robin that was one of the bigger
ones
okay in recent years were you there yet
yeah i played in that one
wow and so we got to see yes was there
yeah yeah and then
were you
the championship i ever attended in
person was the one you played in
oh back in 2003. yeah in seattle okay we
hosted
three you were there exactly yeah wow
okay so you see
these guys they haven't been coming
since ever since
uh it's come to saint louis for the for
all these uh ten years
now uh i know we love st
louis but how do you feel about the fact
that it's in one place and not bouncing
around like it used to
you know st louis uh the hospitality is
just off the charts here
i i don't mind it back in 2009 when it
first started i was kind of like
boy i hope they move it around a little
bit but i'm very happy
it's centrally located and it's the
macra chess
over here let's talk money a little bit
prize money we talked about how
back you you actually told me this that
that biz guyer won 254 dollars and 35
cents
for winning was that the 194 54 54
championship what do you know the total
prize fund and why that number
35 cents that i don't know i i i
i really okay so i caught you in one you
got to get that fast
i figured i could catch you guys i don't
know everything i'm still learning
myself but i enjoy
consuming as much information about this
event as possible
we appreciate you and all the stats you
give keep them coming
thank you so much thank you edward by
the way
out of boston one thing he and i do is
argue
all day every day how do you feel about
um gronkowski retiring
new england patriots well he went on top
he won the
super bowl we won the world series we
won the world series
stop it we just got off the show
no hold on hold on hold on i mean i
can't let somebody like you just
uh get away because one of the things
that well you talked about streaks
uh first u.s championship yeah when was
it held
1936 in new york that's that's
i really haven't compiled stats prior to
the first
time 1936 so
and it's kind of like ever since then to
now type of thing
yeah with an exception of the year third
edition of the us champion this is the
63rd
uh compare that if you will to maybe
other
countries we have one of the longest uh
national championships
63 years tradition you know yes i really
haven't paid attention to
all that you have enough trouble with
the us
the best one in the world exactly and
and finally
uh before i do let you go uh these
tournaments have been
now 12 player round robin traditional
uh but you mentioned there was an 18
player
in 84. yeah
was that the was that the most number of
players
no i think 1948 and won by herman
steiner had like
20. wow round round 1946 had like 18
they had some they had some odd number
ones too because people would drop out
or something
i see and um but in the 40s they had
long
that's why sammy recepsky was able to
accumulate so many
unbeaten streak because i remember when
i uh first showed my stats to walter
brown in 2003 he said to me
i'm number two on the wins list but you
know sammy was beating a bunch of cab
drivers
i was speeding real chess players
thank you edward very very nice see our
predecessors
boy they had it was rough on them
they they would look at this tournament
say 11 games that's
easy we play 20 games against one